hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new episode of the witching hour i am
perry this is haley and this time around
we have a guest that we are very excited
about it is the director of demonic it's
neil blom count neil hello
congratulations how you doing welcome
good i'm i'm good thank you yeah thank
you for having me so just so everybody
knows demonic is going to be available
in theaters and everywhere you can rent
a movie on august 20th just so you know
that right up top but right now
we wanted to go back to the very very
beginning for you because one thing that
we just love discussing for fun in
general is
when you were super young what was the
horror movie that scared you the most
uh
you know i think it may have been
trying to think what really just drove
me to you know a different state of
paranoia it may have been
maybe an alien actually
um alien scared me a lot uh and i know
we're talking about science fiction
horror with that one but that one left
uh left to severe severe traumatic um
scar
i'm trying to think what else really
affected me
i think the omen also i was quite young
when i saw the omen that was another one
that was like
i had issues with that
okay so like thinking back on
them from sort of an adult's point of
view what do you think it was about
those particular approaches to horror
that really unnerved young neil
actually wait i have another one that i
just remembered and this i think i was
six or seven with this
and this is hilarious it was uh eddie
murphy's the golden child
and remember remember the demon flying
around at the end of that
like that that was problematic for me
that was like a huge issue yeah so i was
i was uh i was not i was not stoked with
that we have not heard that one before
excellent
yeah i know i was trying to think like
what was i you know sitting up at three
in the morning stressing over and like
that phil was high on the list
what about the movie that you watched
the most often that one that was just on
on repeat and you couldn't get enough of
uh that's when i was a bit older that
probably would have been um it would
have been aliens i think
like i actually told sigourney that i i
had a copy of aliens and vhs that i kind
of
legitimately wore through
the the tape you know you start getting
artifacts in the tape and it was like
that was that was actually
that was the one that i watched the most
um
but in south africa then i mean i guess
everything was vhs there were very few
channels so it was more about having you
know physical copies of things
there are certain vhs tapes that i wore
out as a child but that doesn't mean
that i have thrown them away even though
i don't own a vh
i don't because kind of uh everything
like i i was you know it was 1997 when
we got to canada and the move to canada
resulted in like very very few things
coming here it's kind of like a it was
if i think i think if i still lived in
johannesburg i might actually have it
um i just bought batman on v8 on vhs the
other day i saw it in a store so i i
mean i love tim burton's batman so i
have uh i and then i was thinking i need
to i'm going to get a whole bunch of vhs
i think i was just going to say it's
kind of funny that the uh you know the
sequel to the first film that came to
mind that really messed you up as a kid
became the one you couldn't let go of
and kept watching obviously they're
pretty different movies but do you think
that
sort of obsessive relationship with
aliens would have happened if you didn't
have that intensely terrified
relationship with alien first uh it may
not have i mean they they really are
connected um
to for me they're they're definitely
connected i mean the first one with with
alien there's an area in in south africa
that's kind of uh durban is the city and
then there's a there's a small area
called slango which is like a holiday
resort town and we used to go there when
i was when i was a kid and the apartment
block or the you know the sort of
holiday flats that we would stay in
would do this thing where they would
play a vhs they would play a movie each
day on vhs like down on ground level
that would be circulated through all of
the the building on a certain channel
and that was that was where i watched uh
alien at six or seven or something that
kind of like just fractured my head and
then we went down to the beach and i was
like you know playing around on the
beach after seeing giger's xenomorph
and and so then i became kind of
obsessed with it and i went down to the
reception and asked them what it was and
they like showed me the name of the film
and stuff so then when i got back to
johannesburg i
over the next few years kind of tried to
figure out how to get my hands on that
um and then that turned into into aliens
and and then aliens was the one that i
watched more so they're very connected
to one another do you think that there's
any
supernatural horror out there
specifically ones involving aliens that
are kind of tapping into what made those
two movies so special for you early on
because yeah i know we've seen those
franchises continue you're not a
stranger to that but it it feels like
it's been a very long time to me since
we've gotten into that kind of alien
driven terror i mean i wish that was the
case but i'm not sure that that is the
case
i think i think there's also i mean
regardless of the actual movie i think
the way that 21st century marketing
works now
is
you're you're there was a mystique and
like there was something about films
back then that you couldn't get your
hands on anything the only thing you
could do was like find fangoria or
something to like
you know find a black and white photo of
of like onset production like terminator
2 was similar that way for me like i was
completely obsessed with it before it
came out and it was hard to see anything
to do with it and i think the amounts of
saturation now with stuff just
everything regardless of how good the
movie is there's like a feeling of
that things are disposable you know the
things are it's it's just like you
they're just being churned out
constantly and you there's so much
marketing material that there's no
mystique really about things any longer
to follow up on that is is there any fix
in your mind to preserve that kind of
mystique other than saying you know
let's just not market the movie as much
maybe not really in hollywood not in the
system that is now like up and running
you'd have to you'd have to be kind of
slightly outside of the system maybe for
that to work
um another one when i got slightly older
this didn't scare me it was just
something i got very into was i mean a
lot of carpenter's stuff but um but the
thing as well
uh was like way up on that list um
predator was high up on that list this
is like now like sort of like 10 to 13
years old more i think the shining too
weirdly i was very into then i was into
the abyss as well
solid selection there i don't know if
you could tell we don't like the thing
at all over here
yeah i don't know yeah no no it doesn't
look like it
i'm kind of curious you know you talk
about the the marketing and this is
jumping jumping head a little bit but it
it stood out to me and it was something
i wanted to ask about the idea of
making demonic in secret you know the
the headlines were all neil bonkat made
a secret horror movie uh was that a
factor in why you wanted to approach it
that way or or if not what was sort of
the motivation to do it no no i don't
think so i think i think that's a
symptom of like making a tiny budget
film
like it's like i think and also by the
way uh ip that nobody knows about right
like
people people
the the level of of red hot scrutiny and
and you know constant uh searching for
things online comes with ip that's
massively established that has a huge
fan base
and so when you combine
none of that with a tiny budget you
don't have to work hard to make
something secret it wasn't like i wasn't
actually actively doing that at all i
don't think it's just a symptom of it
but i do i do actually agree with you
that that uh
that a
an interesting byproduct of it is
much quieter um marketing in a way that
i really like uh which is which is cool
you know um and one of the one of the
things that i did
uh i have a few eight millimeter cameras
from the 60s and
i sh we didn't have behind the scenes so
i just shot stuff on eight mil for fun
like between setups
and um
ifc actually used that for
a small piece of marketing which is
awesome so it's like black and white
and color stock with no sound
what is this marketing and where can i
find it uh i can i can find it and send
it to you yeah i think it was more it
was it was like almost like social media
level stuff but it was um
when i was shooting it i had no idea
what would happen with it and i just
thought it would be awesome to
you know to to document something that
is in the horror space with something
that feels like the tools that you would
have used in 1977 to like film behind
the scenes it just felt cool and it's
hilarious that there's no sound so you
know um it has a it has a nostalgic
authentic cool feel about it that i
really like i dig that uh
going back a little we did want to touch
on district 9 and the beginning of it
all in the feature film realm for you
but specifically i know that uh you had
a relationship with peter jackson early
on he went on to produce district nine
which is a huge deal for a new filmmaker
getting into hollywood but it was making
me wonder is there any you know us like
a smaller piece of advice that he gave
you way back then that maybe you didn't
think was a big deal at the time but now
that you're so much further on in your
career you find yourself thinking is
isn't valuable and you just didn't
recognize it at the time well i mean
firstly i agree with you that it was
like just a massive uh massive leg up
and a bonus in an immeasurable way that
he
uh that he produced that film and also
that he was that he you know
got me on to direct halo which he was
producing um
but i mean there were a lot of things i
learned from pete like uh
i hadn't at that point i'd never been
around a filmmaker of that stature and i
think i i wouldn't say it was like one
piece of advice it's more just soaking
up
being around someone who's done what
he's done and kind of seeing how he
approaches filmmaking
it was very eye-opening for me
um
one the one thing that was said when we
were writing the script because um terry
who wrote it with me she she and i would
go over to peter and fran's house and we
would discuss um
the story and one of the things that
came out of one of those sessions that
was really a line that i always remember
is
is because it's like common with writing
to kind of like just you know get stuck
and hit the breaks and just kind of
go off and
decide to not work on it for a while and
the the one line that i always remember
from there was write it wrong to write
it right so just like write just do it
and then evaluate it and then modify it
so um but yeah i would say in general it
was more a case of
soaking things up by
um
sort of osmosis was was more uh
long-term meaningful i would say
write it wrong to write it right is an
interesting
uh
concept and this probably reveals a
little too much about my own self-doubts
but like how do you then know when
you've gotten it right like what's your
journey to take you past the point of
knowing you just need to get it out to
where you feel that you you hit the spot
it needs to be i think it's more a case
of evaluation like um you can go back
and and read it and see what feels wrong
and then adjust it so
um
where i think what happens a lot of the
time is that you may not actually put it
down on the page because you're second
guessing stuff yeah it was an
interesting process though that whole
that the whole thing was was a really
interesting time because
i had looked at what a lot of directors
that i like ridley scott was a director
that was like very influential to me and
i loved what what he had made obviously
like like everyone does and
he had gone through commercials
uh for a very long time actually he was
a commercial director and then
had gotten into feature films and then
and then you start realizing that david
fincher had done this and like lots of
directors have done this so
as i was coming out of animation i
wanted to
i wanted to do that as a stepping stone
to getting into um into feature film
directing like my eye was on features
like pretty much from the time i got to
canada
and one thing that happened that was
hugely beneficial was
um
was ridley scott's production company
which was at the time was rsa films
signed me as a commercial director
so
because of rsa's connection to hollywood
um
jules daley who ran rsa had me meet a
bunch of hollywood agents because i had
no agent uh
and i met a sequence of them and the
final person that i met was ari emanuel
who i instantly really loved because ari
is just you know this larger-than-life
personality and i ended up signing with
him in wme and that
that sort of um
help that that provided to me was
something that got
mary parent who was producing halo and
who had produced uh king kong with with
with peter um he got her my stuff that i
had made up until that point and she
gave it to pete and so
you can kind of track this sort of you
know i it was like doors were opening
for me because
of this
this sort of luck that i was getting in
in getting agents like ahri and then
where that led to and so it was it was a
very
it was a very quick moving time that was
very cool but i also was skeptical about
halo i thought that what i i always kind
of wanted to do my own stuff
and i felt like what would happen
would be that i would be a young
director that would just be thrown into
a meat grinder essentially working on
like a giant studio film with giant ip
and
i don't know whether that would have
happened or not because pete may have
actually protected the process but what
what ended up happening in that film
dying and the birth of district 9 was
more beneficial to me
um because i got back to being able to
do my own stuff
um but with the support of like a really
really you know awesome filmmaker so it
was it was a good it was a good process
but it was difficult going through it
so not only do you get to make your own
film for your first big feature but then
that that film goes on to get academy
awards which is i mean it's just one
heck of a way to start a feature
directing career we don't hear about
that too often so given that that was
your very first film you name dropped a
whole bunch of people who had so much
experience in the industry that were
behind you on all this
is there any you know key advice that
you got just in terms of you know
keeping industry expectations for all
future projects in check and also
keeping your own expectations for
yourself in check as well i think
district 9 is uniquely tied to
um to socio-political and sort of racial
discussions that are the result of
living in south africa and i think those
topics are very interesting to me
um i mean elysium has a lot of the same
kind of class warfare
uh
structure about it so
i i feel like i'm naturally interested
in that topic but i think district 9
also set me up in a way where audiences
expect me to make that
to make films in that topic range more
than like over the next 10 years maybe
40 percent of the stuff i do is in that
zone i'm still super drawn to it but i
need the leniency to be able to go in
other directions too
so the way that i look at it is i'm just
going to do what i'm going to do and
people are either going to like it or
not they're not going to like it there's
nothing else really that you can do
right because otherwise you become
subservient to just wanting to make one
kind of film to please people
and
i don't want to do that
not to box you in but with that that
idea in mind
given how much has happened since the
release of district 9 just in the real
world topics that you could tackle in a
potential sequel how might the district
9 sequel idea
have turned out had you rolled right
into it after the release of the first
film versus on what your versus what
you're working on now that's kind of
exactly what i mean you know you would
have been just making a sequel for the
sake of making a sequel which i didn't i
just actively didn't want to do um
so
it took a long time to
uh and it wasn't that i was trying it's
that i i had an idea and i and i saw
something that
made the concept of a sequel click like
that gave it meaning and and gave it a
reason for existing
um
and then i started going down that road
so
uh you know so that's that's the script
that we're working on
you know you mentioned the
element and how you you haven't not done
it but you don't do it all the time
so as you're as you finally found the
reason for this and you're making your
way not just back into the
sociopolitical elements but that very
same world
uh do you feel that your
perspective has significantly evolved
over like this decade how was that like
just they're heavy themes to reckon with
in general but also going directly back
into the same world is quite a yeah yeah
i know it yeah i mean definitely the
last
it feels like the world in general is in
like a very chaotic place that's
becoming ever more complex and ever more
unstable
if it feels like there is something that
you truly feel like you are saying then
you should attempt to say it you should
attempt to make it and if you don't feel
that way then what is the reason for you
making it at all
um so so if if the if you come to the
conclusion that it is something that
that you think
you really believe in and you want to
make then then the question is
our audience is going to like it is it
is it too different is it too similar
you know what where do you fit in with
that and
you you you will never really be able to
know the answer to that so you have to
just commit to doing it and see what
happens with it because there's kind of
no other way to approach it like
chappie's the same thing right like i
just really wanted to make chappy and i
i kind of did what i think i was setting
out to do and the audience typically
doesn't like the movie
so does that mean that you shouldn't
take risks and do stuff oh you have the
chappy artwork that's awesome i i love
the movie quite a big crappy fan
this wasn't even planted here it is
always which is just there yeah
that's serious though
that's awesome
um but i mean like if you if you did a
sort of aggregate you know way that
people respond to it it's like
i can understand why a lot of people
responded negatively to it but my point
is i would rather i would rather have
five or six films that don't work and
have one film that really does work
because you were continuously trying to
do stuff that was a bit odd or a bit
unusual
rather than a finely tuned um
you know expectation machine that like
is not pushing anything too far and that
you know in a generic sense how the
audience is going to react
so i kind of don't want to do that you
know i'd rather be more of a wild card
and more more
just i don't know just freer to do stuff
really and just see what happens this is
kind of more of like a craft theory
question because it obviously didn't
happen this way but i'm wondering
where do you think you would be craft
wise today if not for oats and the
freedom to explore that that outfit gave
you because a lot of directors are just
very beholden to the studio system it's
like they wait for the green light or
they can't create and evolve but
you created something where you can
consistently be playing no matter what
everybody around you says
yeah i i love oats i mean i really
really love oats and i spent a lot of
time over the last few years the first
few years were about
um
were about making content and now since
then it's been about like on a business
level like how can you figure out what
to do with this in a way where it's it's
sustainable and i i'm getting closer to
figuring that out and
once
that is in place i feel like it would it
would be very
if it works it could be extremely um
creatively beneficial to me to just kind
of be able to do that it was i really i
really enjoyed the time
away from hollywood to just go and do
that and not really care you know i mean
i love the idea of making youtube videos
like a lot i think youtube creators are
amazing actually like
um
there's probably more there's a lot of
creativity there in a way that isn't
stifled uh by you know by by corporate
um systematic filmmaking and i love that
so
yeah
i'm a fan
i'm also a big fan of votes so i was
kind of just curious like on a status
update there because you still talk
about it very frequently on social media
it's been a minute since we've seen
something new obviously been a hell of a
couple years the world's been going
through so that makes sense but just i'm
i'm curious what's what's up for you
guys what are you guys doing well i mean
so if you the youtube channel if you
look at it now represents about 16
million dollars
of of of content right that's what it
costs to have the minutes that are on
there at the present second
um so you can't just do that and put up
youtube videos there has to be
i don't think we've gotten a dollar from
anything i mean we saw some merchandise
but it's like there's no structure to it
so there was an original idea and the
way that i originally went about making
it which um
we didn't go down that road and the
system that we were going to put it on
ended up changing so that's that's fine
but um but now i feel like i'm getting
closer to a new structure that would
allow this to continue so it has been a
minute and it has been uh just an
internal sort of like reorganization of
things but hopefully i can make it make
it work and then i can be in that and i
can be in hollywood
because i'm actually stoked to be back
in hollywood to be honest like i i feel
now like i'm as much as i love oats i'm
also willing to like hit the ground
running now for a bunch of movies that i
want to make just because i'm curious i
don't even know how much you're able to
say about what your plans for the future
of oats is but you know you just brought
up how much you like the creative
freedom of youtube does the future of
oats rely on the rise of streaming
services and maybe new unique platforms
that we have out there now
i would say probably not
because streaming services are still
within the ecosystem of hollywood it
just it just behaves differently right
it's kind of like you have to know that
beast and like work with it or
youtube is radically different right
it's a totally decentralized system that
just lets people um put up whatever they
want i mean it's quite amazing
and and uh the revenue streams wouldn't
be from youtube it's just that youtube
would be the place that you could
witness the stuff that you know that is
up there but
but no i i i mean the stream the
streamers are the same as as as the film
studios it's all the same it's the same
kind of process that you go through
right it's just it's a different way of
of doing things
coming off of that um experience what
what do you think it
was that made you ready to hit the
ground running with studio projects now
um i i just i don't know i just feel i
feel like i took you know i took some
time off i really liked what we did with
oats and i feel like i
i like the idea of um making
some projects that exist in this larger
three-act
you know
mythological storytelling kind of
setting where i i i think
i think it's why i like feature films
more than tv in general is that there is
it is operating on a slightly
more campfire mythological kind of
experience it's something you take in at
once
and short films don't do that and tv
doesn't do that and i think being at the
right
you know the right budget level with the
right story in features does do that so
i think it's more of a creative thing
really than anything i just feel like i
want to do it now
all right digging into demonic
specifically now
i i guess let's just start with a big
broad question where did the uh the
beginnings of the idea come from because
you know from my limited perspective i
watched the movie and i'm like well you
could either start with wanting to make
a demonic possession movie or you could
have the idea for this technology at the
core of it you know it was kind of
actually both i mean it was very the
this film is very weird and unusual in
the way that it came about because
it's kind of a it's it's almost like a
hybrid between oats and filmmaking in a
sense
because i
i i i was i was ready to go back into
hollywood and start directing some films
and
and then the pandemic happened
and it was like everything i didn't want
to sit around and not work on anything
for you know for for several months
while we were figuring out what was
going on and i always had this obsession
with
paranormal activity and blair witch
project in the way and this probably
goes back to youtube and oats and
everything else and the way that
i love the idea of filmmakers going out
with your own resources and doing stuff
even a decade ago i remember thinking i
want to make
a self-financed horror film at some
point because i love i just love that
idea so i kind of
had that in the back of my head
again
it felt like it was a gap in time that
would be
a good a good place to kind of
experiment with that idea and so when
when i decided to do that then i i
looked at a few different concepts that
i had
um one of them was a bit more
experimental and a bit a bit more like
something that would be very well suited
to oats which is the idea of using
volumetric capture
and which is how the simulation scenes
were rendered
um
and i knew i wanted to use that but i
knew that the technology was very new
and very early and very kind of glitchy
in the way that it looked and unless you
could come up with
a narrative reason why that would be in
the movie
it you you wouldn't really be able to
use it and then separately from that i
also had this idea of the vatican um
operating in more of a nefarious 21st
century way like a different way of
looking at the catholic church and and
exorcisms and um
the trope of
of you know the vatican within the the
horror context as it was i was thinking
like what would it look like if it was
more using its own capital to buy up
silicon valley tech companies and
more of a
just a different approach to it so i
kind of merged those two ideas
and
and coming from wanting to make
something like paranormal activity it
was like well you probably have a
demonic possession element and that when
you combine that with vr
it just kind of the film just sort of
emerged it was an emergent process of
just combining things and you know
working working on a horror film during
the pandemic
you've done like a lot of genre blending
throughout your career which makes a lot
of sense now that you list like the
movies you were really hooked on when
you were younger
but there's something about you said in
a recent interview you're very
interested in the near future of science
fiction and that certainly applies here
but how did putting in such a strong
paranormal element which is a bit you
know aliens robots they fit within the
sci-fi realm really securely
how did the demonic element of demonic
well i didn't mean to say that that's
fine challenge you in new creative ways
the biggest challenge was more just a
directorial style really than anything
because
i mean it's hilarious that it's like the
most you know it's by far the cheapest
film that i've done but it's also the
most
controlled and stylistically sort of
very precise so like the camera the
camera moves and the editing pace and
the the sort of shot selection and the
way that things were assembled it was
very different to the other stuff that
i've done on purpose it was much more
mechanical and much more
it was designed
what i really the only thing i was
really trying to do was create this this
simmering
tension that was underneath the film the
whole time like a sense of like dread
that was floating around
and so i would say um it was more it was
more of the the biggest creative
thing that i was aware of was wanting to
slightly alter my directing style to fit
that
more than anything else and that and i
guess that comes with the idea of
slotting in demons and
you know this more religious
horror
point of view compared to the other
stuff i've done before
i have two uh i guess seemingly silly uh
naming questions for you the firs the
first one is i just love hearing about
how someone settles on the title of the
movie because similar to my question
before it feels like you know you could
go demonic bigger bro big and broad or
you can come up with a title that more
specifically gets at the unique
technology that's specific to your film
so yeah what was it that drove you to
demonic ultimately
um well the actual name of the film for
the longest time was unlocked it was
always called unlocked and we we
referred to that pretty much like right
up until
just before ifc bought it
and agc studios and stuart kept saying
that
people are just not going to associate
it with a horror film
and so i i jotted down a bunch of other
titles and
demonic just seemed incredibly
direct like just
incredibly direct and i was like and i
but i wrote a few down and they came
back with just loving demonic because
obviously it you know very firmly puts
it in the genre genre that it's in and i
kind of liked how
laser
pointed direct it was so i was like okay
demonic it is
very much respect that choice yeah the
other naming question that i have for
you and this this might be a better
question for for carly to answer from
her perspective as well but
how do you come to the decision to name
a character the same name as the actor
playing
i just wonder from their perspective
that you know gets you into the role
more or that creates any confusion i
don't even know
so
um this the whole reverse engineered
like process that i described this movie
took right which is much more of
building a movie out of puzzle pieces so
the pandemics on we have the oats
mentality like let's just put some some
stuff together and shoot a horror film
during this period right so when you're
putting those puzzle pieces together one
of the things is
which which actors would be cool to work
with like not only in this environment
but just talented actors in general so
carly i had done work with innote and i
really loved working with her and i
thought she um had the you know the the
the talent level to just bring this
character to life so
before like in the process of blending
volume capture and vr and the vatican
and like these elements
um
before the script existed i knew that i
wanted her in the lead of something i
just named her carly and it just stuck
and then i kind of did that with
everybody else um like i mean well
michael i didn't but michael rogers
chris williams martin
uh carly they were all in oat stuff and
i wanted i just wanted them back and
something that i was working on and it
just it felt like the right mentality
and i knew from an acting perspective
they would be really awesome and then
uh candace mcclure and um and terry chen
were
i i knew both of them and carly
knew them even better and and we
discussed a lot this idea of like the
team that we were building and how to do
the film and she sort of like
re-reminded me about them and so and i'm
you know a huge fan of both of them so
then they ended up in the film so
everyone is kind of from this
very much like puzzle assembly process
um and so that's how her name is carly
and it's uh chris's name is chris for
the longest time all right sticking with
the the seemingly silly questions now i
have one more tiny detail that i was
dying to ask you about
what does carly the character like do
for work in the movie because there is
there's one shot i think she's in the
kitchen and there's a whole bunch of
like brown paper bags that like i don't
know looks like she's designing gift
bags or something and i was dying to and
i think there's cookies on the table
what does she do why are those bags
there
yeah those are two separate things like
what she does and why the bags are there
but um you know we just cut we cut the
film down to just get it to like you
know a quicker um pace despite the fact
that i actually wanted it to move slower
so the cutting pace is slow but scenes i
took out scenes that weren't moving the
story forward so one of them is
a coffee shop that we filmed in um here
i think that she's a barista so we
actually shot a whole scene with her as
a coffee barista um which is cool and
then the gift thing those were uh like
charity gift baskets that she was
putting together for um for charities
that she's a part of and then i and then
i just ended up cutting the i cut i cut
the scene that kind of explained those
but i was like people will probably
wonder what these are and that's
interesting in a horror movie haley well
knows that i focus on tiny details like
that like i'm the one that's going to
catch them so i had to ask you yeah
yeah it's it's uh i think there's one
shot of her leaving the coffee shop that
we kept when she gets into her car when
she's putting on her absolutely amazing
1980s jacket that like incredible
parachute jacket thing that she has
that's my favorite piece of wardrobe in
any film ever
well i mean speaking about tiny details
do you think we should should move into
the spoiler section because i know we've
got some some questions to to talk about
what you guys said
yeah do you do you want to go first
haley or or should i oh please i know
you've got plenty just in case this is
this is the time if you have not seen
demonic you know what to do go watch it
again
on august 20th you can rent it anywhere
or see it in theaters and then come back
to this conversation so this is it your
one and only spoiler warning
i have
just so many world building questions
here and it's it's funny you said that
earlier about preferring the feature
film format to television because when i
walked away from demonic all i kept
thinking was this is an idea that would
really well suit i guess like the
anthology format where
i want to see all of the different
outfits that the vatican has purchased
and what they're doing differently in
each one of them so do you picture that
world being you know this theraple is
doing it this way but another place in
another country or another city is doing
it a different way yeah exactly i mean
like the way that i was explaining this
concept of of knowing i wanted to do
something like paranormal activity and
then dusting off ideas off of a shelf
the vatican idea
which i had for a few years before was
much bigger in scale than than a
hilariously you know smaller horror film
it's kind of cool that it's in this
horror film actually i'm stoked but if
you were to make
other films at a larger scale the
concept was
the original concept was
if demonic possession is real
and if the vatican and the you know the
catholic church goes about um
training priests on how to exercise
demons
then could mass murderers in history
have been attributed to demonic
possession
so could you have dictators or like
global level you know genocidal events
be
be the result of a demonic possession
and if that was the case how would the
vatican go up against a dictator
and their army
so it was like a very much larger sort
of
you know borderline geopolitical concept
um
and
and so it's it's scaled down for this in
the sense that they're
they're buying the vr they're buying the
company that specializes in medical
virtual reality um because it would be
an interesting way to sniff out who was
possessed and who isn't actually
possessed
so i i would actually be really
interested in making other films that
scale up
in terms of production size to
see what else the vatican is in fact
doing
i don't know if this is pushing that too
far or if you've even thought this far
ahead but if in this particular location
they're using virtual reality is there a
possibility that some somewhere else is
doing a more you know like grounded
boots on the ground traditional as we've
seen it in exorcism movies kind of ways
of attacking these demons yeah yeah no
for sure it would be it would be
everything it would be
it it's an attempt to portray
the trope of the vatican and the
catholic church in in a much more 21st
century sort of realistic way
um and so it would be
all elements it would be from just the
single priest all the way up to taking
on governments
a related question i'm very
fascinated and disturbed by the idea of
militarized exorcism and i'm curious how
you how do you envision the training for
something like that how does like a boot
camp and like priest training combined
in your mind
well the the the militarized element was
was
what i was thinking is
you don't use any of those skills or
those weapons in in dealing with in
exercising a demon that would be
something that would be much more like
traditional um i mean the vatican
actually offers courses in real life to
priests to train them on how to be
exorcists right because the assumption
is the demons are in fact real
so the way that you would deal with the
actual demon would be far more like what
we've seen in demonic possession movies
before with crosses and priests but
but if it skips bodies if it starts if
it if it's a physical body that you have
to try and like neutralize in order to
try to do an exorcism
then it can then it's a physical danger
to you
so the my thinking was like the the
patient or the person who is possessed
would be would be cuffed and ha like
really strapped down in a way that the
priests can do what they need to do but
if it if it's skipping bodies in a way
that's immaterial and it's taking over
other forms like um
like a zazzle in the denzel washington
film
then
you have a serious issue on your hands
right and that's where the militaristic
element comes in
and as it happens in this film that's
precisely what happened is it skips out
of her mother into michael
and
they you know it's like a massive
firefight that we don't see
for budgetary reasons and then uh and
then we pick up with you know michael is
now possessed
um
so
that's the thinking behind it i guess
the training would be a combination of
first you they'd probably just hand
select like priests that are very high
ranking like good exorcism style priests
and then train them for layer two how
about the the design of the demon that
we wind up seeing were there are there
any uh you know previous influences in
film and television that you took from
or or any kind of
actual research that you did in order to
formulate that look and design and
ability
i love that creature so much it brings
me endless joy like it's massive beak
and stuff it's just absolutely
hilariously terrifying but um this film
is very strange in the sense that i find
it very difficult to point to references
for it
i it's weird it's like it feels like
everything to do with this movie was
just sort of created in a vacuum
and um i know that there are obviously
subconscious references but i don't i
just don't really know what they are i
guess maybe the exorcist with
the upside down spider walking but i
also know that i was obsessed with
troy james who is the performer who did
that and i saw his stuff and just wanted
him i wanted to work with him on
something so
so i can't really point to the exorcist
so in terms of designing the creature
there's nothing that i am consciously
aware of that i can point to what i what
i think happened is
i was
just in the pandemic and and then
to do with
to do with these topics i was reading a
lot about the the plague in the middle
ages and the the plague masks that they
would wear and i think that that has a
beak-like quality that may have just
sort of
morphed neurologically into the idea of
a crow and a raven and i'm also
interested in crows and ravens and i
have an african grey parrot
i don't actually know i know that i
wrote down in the script exactly exactly
what is in the movie and i gave that
write up to
this amazing concept artist
her name is eve ventrue and like if you
have the chappy art book which you do
you may be very interested in eve's
artwork it's amazing so i gave i gave
eve the write-up and she sent back
i gave her the write-up and i also gave
her some references of um not only like
black crow and raven feathers but also
like
um
very coarse
kind of
shitty goat and wool hair like hairs as
well and it was sort of a combination of
those so the surface would be sort of
exposed bone and ribs like black bones
and ribs with these hairs and these
feathers and then the you know the
general kind of avian approach to the
the beak and
and anyway she sent back
one image that was the easiest concept
design process i've ever done in my life
she just sent back the image basically
that was like i want that exact thing in
the movie
and um
then i gave that to
verna pretorius's company amazing ape
and they built a seven foot like 1980s
you know monster suit with an
animatronic beak
uh and then we we filmed obviously we
filmed sequences like when it comes out
of your closet where it's a physical
suit performer but
what was more unique and more weird was
that we also used that suit in the
volumetric capture stuff which is
incredibly strange conceptually in
visual effects to because everything now
is a computer-generated monster so it's
like oh i wish i could see the
occasional suit-based real monster that
would be cool like it feels a little bit
more like you know nightmare on elm
street or something
and what so but people always build them
in cg so this idea of building it
physically and then digitizing it into
cg is just like
so backwards and bizarre but that's what
happens in the simulation sequences
she's seeing a digital representation of
a physical suit performer in a physical
suit hearing you describe that makes me
realize why i like the look of it across
the board in this movie so much and it
also makes me like is that a
is that like a practical reasonable way
for other movies out there to maybe
steer away from creating something
entirely digitally and still be able to
play with it but start from a practical
place
the problem with volumetric capture is
you cannot play with it that's the thing
that's so weird about the process right
like
motion capture
makes a lot of sense to audiences and
and makes a lot of sense to filmmakers
because you can infinitely adjust it you
can apply the motion of the face and the
motion of the body to any
creature or you know
bipedal anthropomorphic thing that you
want and you can refine it forever um
volumetric capture on the other hand
is
is three-dimensional capture of your
actors in hair and makeup and wardrobe
in a way that they are locked in the
same way that if you were to film them
with normal cameras
on a normal shooting day you can't
adjust that footage unless it went into
hardcore visual effects so
vulcap is the same thing you just get
exactly what it is that you captured and
there's nothing you can do to it and
and that's why
the fidelity of it needs to be a few
years out from where it is now for it to
be like mass adopted because
what you see in the movie is kind of for
the actor to have any space to move
um because obviously the resolution
would increase as the cameras get closer
to them
so to move the cameras back barely
enough to have them be able to move the
resolution drops off to where it where
where it is in demonic so
i would be very curious to see what
other filmmakers would do with it
another thing that i'm curious about is
if there is any real world truth in the
technology that we see the priests using
in the movie because i i know it's you
know it's fictional but i find in these
kinds of scenarios there are always like
tiny nuggets that maybe in the real
world we are kind of on the cusp of
actually applying
well i for me it was definitely
generated backwards it was generated
from the idea of wanting to use volume
capture which led me to vr which led me
to coma patients that may be possessed
but once once i had that i did go and
look into it to see if there was
anything
and the only
the
the answer is basically no but the
closest thing would be
it would be a newer link
right from elon musk it's like that
they're they're
there's actually there's another
valve which is a very well-known video
game company is also experimenting i
think with uh with brain computer
interfaces
um and so somewhere between
what valve is doing and what newer link
is doing
um
it's it's kind of like nothing is really
like it's portrayed in the movie yet but
i think it will get there surprisingly
quickly i think all of a sudden it'll be
because all you're really doing is
you're just intercepting
the the optical nerve or you know you're
taking any one of the senses and
interrupting them and then redirecting
them to something else which is
theoretically completely possible and
kind of i think proven as well so
i i think it'll suddenly begin to happen
that there could be things like uh like
therapol
i can't tell if that excites me or
disturbs me but i i like can't help but
to be so fascinated and intrigued to
hear more about that
yeah but the idea of people being able
to spy on your dreams really freaks me
out man that feels like one of the last
things we have left that isn't digitized
i think i think that the first thing
that will happen will probably be some
corporation like beaming ads into your
dreams
there you go so it's just sort of like
has a like a pepsi taco bell sort of
vibe to the dream you know that could
happen
i think i think i might pass on that
application of it um here here's another
very like story specific thing that i
was wondering about
so they mentioned that they need carly
in order to communicate with angela in
previous uses of technology just you
know in our imagination right now in a
you know a previous attempt to
communicate with someone who was
possessed before this incident are they
able to communicate with the person who
is possessed or is that specific to
angela where she just won't talk to them
that's specific to her i think that the
demon is essentially going kind of crazy
itself because it's stuck in a person it
drove a person it drove the meat vessel
that it was inside of
hard enough that it gave it a brain
injury that uh
that that you know paralyzed it inside
of it
its host is paralyzed so i think it's
going absolutely insane running around
in the inside of her mind and the images
that it keeps seeing inside of her mind
if it sifts through memories are mostly
related to this girl
which is now a new interesting target
for it
so um
it's manipulating the the doctors
to make it bring
the subject that it can skip to that
it's now interested in which is her it
could pick anyone it's interested in her
um so
and because it's it's in control of the
mother's mind it's not letting the
doctors
uh access her in a way that that they're
comfortable with which makes them start
thinking
that she is in fact possessed and the
other 99 patients that sarah paul are
not so then they persuade the daughter
to come in and then it like they're
correct
i was thinking about this while i was
watching it but hearing you lay it out
so clearly like that makes me really
want another version of this movie that
takes place in the tan in the same uh
time yeah but from the demon's
perspective yeah just hang out with him
in there you don't really get many
movies from the demon's perspective and
i would love to know what that kind of
frustration looked and felt like
yeah he's uh i think he's not
i think he's i mean he's not great he's
not he's not a great great great guy
probably not awesome to spend time with
yeah um i am curious on that note like
um it sounds like you very much came up
with the demon design yourself and and
with your creature designer but do you
are you the type who would want to look
at actual demonic texts or does that
kind of freak you out or you know how
much did you look to the actual
religious text of demonology
i looked through some of it i mean there
was something about the the
reverse engineering of the film that
just felt right to just kind of make it
up
if that makes sense i didn't really want
to say like this is this demon which is
well known
um but i did look up some of it um
you know there were some interesting
things um
yeah it was it was mostly a case of of
not pulling from reality and just kind
of making it up i mean one one thing i
really wanted to do was i wanted
i wanted the creature to have
a very specific area that it kind of was
its zone that it maybe couldn't really
stray out of unless it was in a body
so when it's immaterial and it's
floating around then it wants to it
wants to mesh itself into a person they
need to cross through a rough
geographic area that it occupies
and
i wanted the priest to have to take the
person back to that point to exercise
them you can't really exercise it just
anywhere
or you can't kill it anywhere you can
only kill it like on the sacred piece of
of you know square footage and then
someone made the mistake of building a
sanitarium over that which is what they
always do
of course yeah um we have to let you go
soon haley do we want to do the last two
mind as well i'll i'll give you the uh
the softball question first because we
kind of already know the answer to this
but we we really ask every single guest
this do you have any
pets i mean
like my wife is obsessed with animals so
my pets would be three dogs eight horses
a parrot
winner
that's by far the most number we've ever
heard oh really
um
but i would say out of those the one dog
is a pomeranian
which his name is digby but i call him
the red devil
and he's uh has more personality in it
than most of the dogs in like if you
combined all of the dogs in west and
canada this dog probably has more
personality than all of them but he's
also sometimes a complete [ __ ]
but it's my favorite animal i think i've
ever had though as well which is strange
um so so yeah digby is uh very high on
the on the list i'm now a big dip digby
fan yeah sounds great for that fan club
as well it's like a mixture of like
extremely cute and totally terrible
yes that sounds like a combination that
definitely works in digby's favor
and our
we also always ask our guests
you know we like to pick your brains for
a little bit of recommendations so is
there anything
you've seen whether it's a movie show or
a book you read or a game you played in
genre
um that you think our listeners should
leave this and go check out immediately
yeah i mean there's there's two books
that i would say um the one is blind
site from peter watts who's a canadian
science fiction author
uh which i read recently and um
actually richard morgan from altered
carbon told me about about peter's work
and said that i needed to check out
blindside and it was like amazing and
the other one um is a book that i'm uh
just totally in love with which i was
actually adapting with fox which i'm not
anymore which is called the gone world
and uh
the gun world by thomas swedelich and um
blindside from peter watts would be the
the two high recommendations for me
excellent like the sound of that says
going on the list
all right we gotta we gotta let you go
but thank you so much for hanging out
with us big congrats on the movie
thank you for having me yeah it was it
was cool hanging out with you guys
glad you enjoyed that's it guys you have
officially survived the witching hour